bonjour nicolas des dizaines de
véhicules ont déjà pris la route quel
est l'enjeu de ce voyage pour les
manifestants
depuis ce matin nous sommes en été et
montélimar montélimar drôme a
aujourd'hui nous étions partis depuis
avignon et ce qui est intéressant ce qui
revient dans la bouche ici des
convoyeurs c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle ils nous parlent d'un convoi de
la libération vous le savez c'est le
combat de la liberté messieurs aussi
pour le congo la libération il c'est
assez intéressant parce que c'est je
disais c'est vraiment il ya beaucoup de
gens ici à montélimar en ce moment il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de gens les convois
commence à s'agréger s'agréger s'agréger
et effectivement c'est extrêmement
intéressant et les gens sont déterminés
mais nouvelle fois il ya beaucoup il ya
des il ya des retraités il y à il ya des
jeunes les couples donc on voit que
c'est quand même bien au delà des chez
les jeunes c'est bien bien nos deux
héros et c'est extrêmement intéressant
et je vous le disais c'est vraiment
cette idée du combat de la libération
ici en télémark ou vraiment il de plus
en plus de monde je dois bien le dire
alors on a après que paris et bruxelles
interdisait tout rassemblement tout le
week-end cela n'entame pas la fameuse
détermination des manifestants
crient c'est charmant non parce qu'on
est au-delà il ya la contestation des
mesures sanitaires on va être clair là
dessus mais il ya aussi vraiment je
disais une faillite démocratique c'est
dire que les gens ont l'impression de
tuer être présenté et ils n'ont pu être
entendus rappelé gilet jaune 3e rang de
novembre 2018 il ya encore la réforme
des retraites pareil après les
manifestations contre le passé ni terre
qui compte ne pas vacciner et
aujourd'hui les gens sont vraiment
déterminés à ils nous le disent a
retrouvé à retrouver leur liberté donc
ça c'est extrêmement intéressant on les
voit extrêmement déterminé et une
nouvelle fois ici c'est vraiment bonne
ambiance et moi je note depuis ce matin
qu'on est parti beaucoup de solidarité
ici beaucoup de victuailles de
victuailles beaucoup de gens qui
apportent aussi il ya des gens qui
viennent faire 20 30 40 km et qu'il est
lâche et finalement on voit que c'est un
énorme convoi je veux le dire populaire
donc ya pas que des idées joignent
attaque d un petit bac 6 10 ans qui
passait vraiment que pour voir populaire
de citoyens qui veulent récupérer
sophie leur liberté et ce qu'ils ont
vraiment l'intention l'objectif de
bloquer la capitale à partir de demain
soir alors les porte parole officiels
que nous avons nous avons nous avons vu
toute la journée avec une discussion par
téléphone valse consignes et finalement
à l'île de france mais c'est vrai que
peut-être une part aussi des gens qui
sont là qui voudraient aller rentrée à
paris ça on ne sait pas très bien on
n'arrive pas à estimer le pourcentage
demi concrètement la version aujourd'hui
des organisations ou des porte paroles
que dire porte-parole finalement c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment de dire nous
irons nous rentrons pas à paris parce
que grosso modo le cortège pour être
brisée si jamais on essayait de ne
finalement passé sur la capitale donc ça
va être une stratégie on va voir ça
demain dans les prochaines heures parce
que ça va se passer demain il ya un
point de ralliement à dijon je crois tu
as 3 et puis en fin d'après midi ce sera
l'arrivée en ile-de-france dont est ce
que qu'on voit il france qu'elle ne
porte pas fortement officiels vont aller
en ile-de-france qui paraît aujourd'hui
le plus plausible mais peut-être que une
minorité voudra vraiment aller sur paris
ça vraiment le saura qu'au fil des
heures nous aujourd'hui la ligne
officielle des organisateurs c'est
l'ile-de-france et ont su grâce à la
captation merci beaucoup nicolas vidal